Narrator: TO MAKE STACKABLE
CHIPS, THEY USE A RATIO
OF 1/3 WATER TO 2/3 POTATO
FLAKES
WITH A LITTLE CORNSTARCH
MIXED IN.
A CONVEYOR DELIVERS THE MIX
TO AN AUGER, WHICH DISPERSES IT.
♪♪
USING FOUR TONS OF PRESSURE,
THEY ROLL THE MIX
INTO ONE LONG POTATO SHEET.
A ROTARY CUTTER
PUNCHES OUT OVAL SHAPES.
A DEVICE PULLS AWAY
THE SCRAP DOUGH,
LEAVING FLAT, UNCOOKED CHIPS.
THE SCRAP DOUGH IS RECYCLED
INTO THE CHIP-MAKING PROCESS.
THE CUT CHIPS HEAD INTO A FRYER.
AS THEY TRAVEL
THROUGH THE FRYER,
ROLLING MOLDS GIVE THE CHIPS
A CONCAVE SHAPE.
THIS SHAPE MAKES THEM EASY
TO STACK.
THE CHIPS SPEND 11 SECONDS
FRYING IN HOT OIL.
THIS MAKES THEM CRISPY.
THEY TRAVEL UNDER BLOWERS
TO GET RID OF EXCESS OIL.
THE CHIPS
GET A COAT OF SEASONING,
THEN DO A BACKFLIP OFF ONE
CONVEYOR ONTO ANOTHER,
FALLING IN NEAT PILES.
A WORKER INSPECTS
THE ROWS OF CHIPS.
THEN IT'S ON TO ANOTHER CONVEYOR
THAT SHAKES THEM UP
TO LOOSEN THE STACKS.
THEY TRAVEL OVER SCALES TO
BE PORTIONED OUT FOR PACKAGING.
AUTOMATED SPOONS FEED THE CHIPS
INTO THE OPEN ENDS OF THE TUBES.
GUIDES TAP THE TOPS OF THE TUBES
TO NUDGE THE CHIPS
INTO POSITION.
GRIPPERS LOWER
THE STACKED TUBES TO A STATION
WHERE SPINNING HEADS
FORCE ON METAL BOTTOMS.
NOW THEY'RE READY FOR SHIPPING.
IT TAKES ABOUT 20 MINUTES TO
MAKE A TUBE OF STACKABLE CHIPS,
BUT IT TAKES LESS TIME
TO POLISH THEM OFF.